now now to a story of hope and
perseverance a dog found stranded near
the peak of an 800-foot mountain in the
northwest valley but our community came
to the rescue getting her to safety
sasha loftis joining us now with this
inspiring story you'll see only here on
eight news now sasha yes david you know
this was really a story that will give
you hope for humanity these five men
stopped what they were doing and risked
their lives to save this dog but they
say they were just doing what anyone
should
if you look at this mountain you'll see
something that doesn't belong a dog
stranded struggling to survive i don't
know how in the world she got there that
question is still unknown but how she
got down is quite the story we started
just seeing all kinds of volunteers
come out of the woodwork a woman first
spotted the pup on a day trek up
cheyenne mountain in the northwest
valley she couldn't get near her so she
asked for help on facebook and that's
when a group of five hikers stepped in i
wasn't coming back without that dog
jeremy kelly scott charlie and ryan
climbed over 800 feet in the middle of
the night to go get her
until you've been up there and
especially at night you don't appreciate
that it's
there's a lot of terrain to
cover cheyenne as she was appropriately
named was understandably terrified so
they slowly coaxed her to safety
once we got her down i it was just it
was it was fantastic it was a selfless
act few could imagine
but these men say they were just
answering the community's call to offer
a second chance to such a beautiful soul
we're just regular guys doing something
that
needed to be done
the cheyenne does not have a microchip
her rescuers are now working with a
local rescue called kiss my paws to
place her if you are interested in
fostering or adopting cheyenne we do
have more information on our website
just an amazing story but she looks so
happy in that video you know i know they
said she slept they rescued her last
night and she slept just all day today
but she was exhausted that's fantastic
it's amazing what they did was
absolutely amazing so hopefully you
watching may know who she belongs to or
help uh take her home yes exactly
information on our website all right
sasha thank you we've been talking about
yeah a great story also christmas tissue
for you
we'll need it we're dog people over here
exactly you had us a dog
my